[Music]
hey what's going on guys the cat is out
the bag the god logic shirts are out
click the link in the description and
head on over to God logic.com to
purchase our first release we just read
let's go I'll see you guys with a shirt
peace all right what's going on
everybody welcome to another video uh my
name is Austin I'm here with Imam and
what's your name again shamin wahed what
he said so I think wahed is easier all
right thank you so much all right so
Imam wahed here uh we're going to be
doing a couple of topics here so the
first topic today um that we're going to
be discussing is the authority of the
scriptures um and I'm going to be coming
from the the lens of the Quran okay and
so I'm I'm you know whenever I get into
the conversation with Muslims and Islam
I think that this is the most important
topic I think that U Muslims and
Christians can come on together is what
does the Quran say about the previous
scriptures um are they corrupted are
they authoritative and stuff like that
and so um from my view from what I've
studied and read I see that the Quran
over and over and over again says that
it confirms what came before it um it
challenges the Christians to judge by
what their scriptures um it tells them
that they have nothing to stand on
unless they stand on the Torah and the
gospel and what has been revealed to
them from the Lord so we we see uh the
perspective of the Quran that the
previous scriptures are authoritative
they're also supposed to believe in the
Quran it points to the Quran it points
to Muhammad's prophethood and
so for me when Muslims say that oh well
what you have is corrupted the Torah and
the gospel has been changed or corrupted
that's where they lose me so um I guess
we yeah that's I'll start it off like
that what do you think well from the
from the Islamic perspective you have to
understand that Muslims believe that God
didn't just communicate to Muhammad that
God also communicated to Abraham to
Jesus to Moses to to all of them so this
is the this is this is this this is the
sense of confirmation okay now in terms
of say for example the Bible that we
have in our hands today does that uh go
along
with uh the Revelation that given to
Muhammad so I suppose is actually the
question so the Muslim response to this
is
essentially that what the confirmation
is of the confirmation is of the fact
that God gave
communication so so god- giving
communication is not the same thing as
first of all if the text that we have
today you know from the the biblical
text is it is it the same thing number
number one and number two is it even
authoritative and let me explain what I
mean about number two first or do you
want to go me continue okay okay yeah so
let me give this a particular example
that that um you know in terms of the
content the biblical content and in
contrast to Chronic content okay all
right so biblical content has Sabbath
right that on the seventh day that God
ceased in the creation in his in his in
his creation Now I admit that generally
Jewish commentators say that this is
they kind of look at this in a sort of a
metaphorical sense of God ceasing in the
action of creation but uh number
Christian writers is take it in a
literal sense whether it's literal or
metaphorical the point here is Sabbath
is observed to to and is observed by
rest it's called is understood to be a
day of rest because God at least at
least in the literal reading of it that
God uh rested now as a result there's a
a particular religious practice the
Sabbath yeah okay although the Bible has
maybe at least one other reason but for
the we're focusing on this one reason
all right so so so the Quran comes along
and first of all the Quran says that
first of all God does not
rest that God first of all it says God
does not rest so as a consequence the
ritual that comes from the idea of God
resting meaning the Sabbath ritual this
not something Muslims observe yeah you
know because the premise of it the
premise of it is from the Islamic
perspective is not correct so then what
I'm trying to give you is an example of
because you're mentioning that the
scripture that the Bible basically your
argument is that the Bible is to be
authoritative to Muslims on the basis of
certain chronic verses and so I'm giving
a practical example to show that it
doesn't really work that way so let me
ask you this then would would it' be
contradictory like if you understood it
in a metaphorical way that God just
ceased from his creation not that he
rested because he was tired would that
necessarily go against Islamic good
question that's a good question so from
an Islamic perspective we say again
referencing the verse of the throne in
the in chapter 2 verse
255 that God does not Slumber rest nor
sleep so we take so even from a
metaphorical perspective we don't we
don't read it in that way right and so
this is actually and I've had this
conversation with many people over the
years this these kinds of language is
among the issues that divide Muslims
from Christians and Jews yeah okay now
from the Islamic
perspective it seems like we're going
directly into this topic rather
than but from an Islamic from the
Islamic perspective in chapter 27: 76 of
the Quran yeah it says indeed this Quran
does give clarity about the majority of
issues that the children of Israel
differ about and I believe that the term
children of Israel references both Jews
and Christians not just Jews okay okay
and as a as a consequence what I'm
saying here using this example of
Sabbath or the idea of of God resting
let me go back to that the idea of God
resting that even as a metaphor Muslims
don't use this even as a metaphor
because it creates a image of God of of
a of a weak God basically yeah but my so
like I I understand how if uh if
somebody can misunderstand that it could
lead to a an you know a bad View God but
if they understood it right in the
correct way that he's just it's not that
he's ceasing because he's tired he just
he saw that it was good and he ceased
from that type of creation the thing is
the thing is is that not everybody is at
the same level true Cornell W I mean
yeah I I often quot quote quote Cornell
West Cornell West says not everybody
wakes up at the same time okay so as a
consequence there has to be very
clear anguage especially on God concept
God concept is the most important issue
in faith okay is God concept so as so
because of that because of that even as
in a metaphorical
sense you know we're we're told not to
use that type of language you know that
that in this case that that God uh
Slumbers or sleeps now directly go back
to what you mentioned before you
mentioned before something about God
ceasing in his activities yeah now I
have to you know really look and see to
be honest with you which particular text
but there is a text that in the Quran
that
implies that God is always at work
really you know there is a text in
chapter again if you give me a moment I
can probably find it but the the point
of the text is that God is always
working so God is God is never let me
ask you this let me this analogy did you
ever see a movie called Bruce Almighty
yeah you remember that movie okay I
think you're a little younger than me
maybe you don't know this movie but
there's a movie called Bruce Almighty
right and so the the storyline of it is
that God played by Morgan Freeman goes
on vacation and he appoints I forgot the
other uh gentleman's name to be his
replacement yeah Jim Cary Jim Carrey
okay he he appoints Jim krey to to fill
in for him while he was he was on
vacation so from the Islamic perspective
that's not from Islamic specific God
never goes on vacation agreed yeah
agreed that's Christian perspective as
well you you know there's actually
because you we are getting to the god
topic but okay okay um but this is still
good yeah yeah so Jesus talks about how
um even on the Sabbath because he's
healing people and stuff like that and
they come at him and they're like how
are you doing this why are you doing
this and he says man is made for the
Sabbath and there something I mean the
sa made for man sorry that that's
another one but in this P this
particular one is in John 5 he says that
my father has been working till now so I
also am working right so it's not that
we we don't believe that God gets
inactive because if he did then all of
universe will collapse right he's
sustaining the universe and all the
creation but um just in that context as
far as like initial creation he saw that
it was good and rested or ceased from
that particular action not that he stops
working all together I mean I I get what
I get what you're meaning I get what you
mean by that I understand I understand
what you're what you're saying but what
I'm what I'm what I'm trying to convey
is the Islamic perspective because the
Islamic perspective how it presents God
it's very
precise it's it's very strong language
very precise very strong fashion and so
so the what the what the Quran does what
Islam does is that it it it makes sure
especially on God concept is to present
God in ways that in in a way that should
not be misunderstood in the in the in
the most fundamental nature because if
we understand God because where does it
stop when if God is on vacation
then where where is where does it stop
if God is on vacation then again who's
who's running the world I mean going
going to the movie going to going to the
I mean there's a some scenes that I'm
remembering from the movie which I don't
know if it's appropriate to share you
know in in this in this in this context
so where where again where does it go
and even you find some ideas in
mythology it says the Greek mythology
where where if God exists then of course
the gods are at War but also you know
God leaving I mean there's there have
been some thinkers who have made that
argument that that God exist even in the
20th 19 19th 20th century that God
exists but then he left he left he left
so the way that the Quran presents the
issue of God concept is is
basically not to not to use that type of
language that could be distorted like
that at all now so so now I I understand
that right now so here's my my question
just for Clarity on this is it
necessarily
contradictory right now I I understand
staying away from this type of language
to avoid misunderstanding but is it
necessarily contradictory you know to
say God doesn't God doesn't sleep or
Slumber in the Quran versus God rested
on the Sabbath day is that necessarily
contradictory if you want to use the
word stopped for for the the sense of
this conversation if you want to if you
want use the word stopped I mean on a
personal level I don't have a problem
with that okay okay on a personal level
I don't have a problem with that if you
want to use the word rest then that
implies uh a weakness and a
contradiction and thus a contradiction
of the idea that God presented in the
Quran that God neither uh uh uh Slumbers
nor nor sleeps so I hope I understand
your question yeah yeah so so you're say
if I'm meaning it in the way of of just
stop then sure if I'm using the word
rest that can imply
these it implies a weak it implies a
weakness it implies a weakness on God's
part and and that's that's something
that for Muslims that we don't go for
and again part of this this conversation
you know again the Quran says that
indeed this Quran gives go gets
clarification on the majority of issues
and so this is perhaps issue number one
okay issue of God concept yeah and so
then so then going with this let's say
that it is a problem like islamically
okay the idea of the of the origin of
the Sabbath okay this would this would
go into um my points about like the
Quran when as it confirms the previous
scriptures if it's saying that the
previous scriptures yes God spoke to
Moses God spoke to these prophets this
he gave them the these scriptures and
when we read these Scriptures it says
God rested on the Sabbath right in a in
a you know correct way yeah how how do
you reconcile that then if the Quran is
contradicting what it said it was what
it said was
correct okay so again I'm gonna
reference sorry start saying Arabic I'm
G again reference 2776 okay okay that
one of the functions of the Quran is to
give clarification on these issues okay
so when when the when the Quran says
that God sent communication to to others
God send communication to Jesus God send
communication to Moses and to you know
what we call the biblical prophets so
then again you have two or three ways to
address that in in terms of
contradictions now now number
one well number one is there is there
interpretation of it that's that we're
missing now you you alluded to that when
you're talking when we're talking about
the issue of God resting period so you
alluded to that is it actual rest as in
taking
or is it or is it just ceasing of activi
so you alluded to that so so so they
have language as as number one and
number two which is perhaps more
controversial obviously from a Christian
perspective is the the preservation of
the of scripture of the text itself yeah
okay so you have these two angles
now now I now I have to sort of share
that what is the Bible and what is the
Quran the Bible the word bible itself
means a
a collection of books me a library so
you have all of this material if if you
count old New Testament you have all of
this material written by different
authors in different times in different
languages even yeah all right so
naturally there was going to be levels
of internal differences number one and
again from an Islamic perspective there
have been some mistakes along the way
now whether they're deliberate or not is
not the point mhm and it's not that the
Quran or Islam is not that it uh uh uh
goes into each and every single issue
all right because for example in in
these Muslim Christian debates often
times mus my approach to these issues is
very different okay often Muslims will
say that know Paul did XYZ
okay that's really not my uh approach
because that's not the quran's approach
the Quran doesn't talk about Paul right
but what it what the Quran does is
focuses on the most important issues
okay it's not it's not for for example
you you to me it looks like wearing a
black shirt and someone else says that
okay it's not black it's purple
okay this is not a big issue yeah okay
whether you're wearing black or wearing
purple this is not this not an important
issue but God concept God concept is an
important issue so it my point I'm
trying to say here is that what the
Quran does it doesn't deny that God
communication to the prophets it doesn't
deny that but it what what it does is is
that it gives clarification on some of
the ways that the scripture has spoken
or or I should say the I I'm going to
change the word from scripture from the
from the way that the uh judeo Christian
tradition I'll use that I think it's a
better way of saying it that that the
way that it has it has spoken yeah I was
going to comment on that because the
verse that you bring that you brought up
and it actually there's a couple of
places where it kind of mentions this
where the Quran is clarifying what the
people defer on right not necessarily
what the scriptures I I don't think it I
haven't seen a verse myself where the
Quran has this view that the scriptures
themselves have falsehood in it or in
inconsistencies so it's like the people
misinterpreting them and so if you don't
mind me sharing a thought about that so
in in chapter 2 verse 79 if memory
serves it says that condemned are those
who write the book write who write the
who write a book a text with their hands
and insert this from God in order to
gain from it a small gain yeah right so
Muslims have looked have have
traditionally looked at this this
statement and and looked at it in a
sense of showing that okay that there
has been you know whether is deliberate
or not there has been some levels of um
uh of alterations or or or Corruptions
within the me within the message of of
the of this of the of the text yeah and
now if and and now if we go into like a
real sort of practical example of of
what I'm talking about here is you know
leave the Old Testament for a moment and
go to new go to if not New Testament
then leads to the the Christian
tradition that emerges the Christian
tradition that emerges is that Jesus
Christ was not only son of God but he's
also God yeah so it it emerges and and
it makes these kinds of uh uh these
kinds of assertions
now I know we're going to probably get
into this part you know in a few minutes
I know we're going to get into this part
in a few minutes but the the point I'm
making in in this context is again that
the Quran comes along and it says that
no no human being can be God God is God
you know and that's that's that's that's
really the uh that's really the end of
that's really the end that part sorry go
ahead so so with like 279 people writing
these fake books claiming these fake
books are from God okay wouldn't that
entail that these these things are
separate from the actual real scriptures
they have like if I if I have a Torah
and a gospel but I decide to write a
book and call it from God that doesn't
mean that I'm distorting the actual
Torah and gospel I just wrote a
distorted book myself and I'm saying
it's from God and teaching it as the
word of God so if if I'm if I'm
understanding what you're saying because
I it's possible that I don't understand
what you're saying but if I'm
understanding what you're what you're
saying uh the thing is is that okay like
for example let's look let's look at
let's look at the let's look at the inil
okay okay the inil so inil is just a
word it's a translation of the of the of
the word good news gospel means good
news that's right that's right right
gospel means good news so so did Jesus
himself walk around with a book not a
physical not a physical book he didn't
he didn't walk around he didn't walk
peace be upon them he didn't walk around
with he didn't walk around with a
physical physical physical book rather
he
embodies the the he he's the embodiment
of good news yes he's embodiment of that
so in a sense that's good he he's
preaching y'all in in well I don't I'm
more of I I consider myself more of a
teacher than a preacher yeah but in any
case he embodies he embodies the the uh
the message but but in terms of because
I'm I'm trying to stay focused on what
you're saying
but in terms of if I understood you
right that let's say that
this maybe I shouldn't do all that let's
say that this is authentic Torah or
authentic gospel yeah and I think what
you're saying is is if you come along
and write the word gospel and write the
word Torah does it have any effect on
that right that's is that what yeah
that's basically what okay okay okay
okay well the thing is is we then we
have to look at the reality of this
thing right that's my point if we have
to look at the reality of this thing and
so the reality of this
thing it rather we're looking at New
Testament or or Old Testament is that
what's the difference between this and
that right not not really anything but
we we we would need to have this in
order to compare right to see if this
actually what I'm saying is if okay if
just because you say that okay you wrote
this one and and is and not this one
is that actually the case then that
that's what that's where the discussion
comes so I'm talking about just the
claim itself from with the Quran so like
it says woe to those who write the book
with their own hands right claiming it's
from God seeking a small price so from
the statement alone it seems to that
that there are people who are writing
books themselves right and and putting
whatever they want in it and asserting
that this is from God but isn't that
what happened with the Bible I mean the
I mean what I mean by that is isn't that
the the the Bible is s is a collection
of writings well I would say that the
Quran then too right the Quran is a is a
collection of the writings it's a
compilation of the recitation and Men
wrote it down right they wrote it with
their own hands and they said this is
from Allah right that they got from the
prophet so anything we have is men
writing with their own hands but what
I'm trying to what I'm trying first of
all there I think there's a there is a
bit of a difference between the the
claims of Islam and Christianity when it
comes to this I think true so in the
sense that what Christians traditionally
claim from what I understand is that the
Bible is the inspired word of God they
don't use the term leral word of God
they use the term the inspired word of
God that that the Holy Ghost gave
inspiration to the the various uh um
authors of the of the New Testament
materials that that's how I that's how I
understand it absolutely correct
absolutely while while the Quran or
Muslims say the Quran is verbatim the
words of ver even the words of M Prophet
Muhammad peace be on him are in a
different textt and they're not even
considered sacred those words are the
words of Muhammad the prophet peace be
upon them are not considered Sac they're
important words yes but they're not
considered sacred words the Quran is
considered sacred words in a sense that
it comes directly from straight from
Allah from Allah so there that's ConEd
uh the most important text for for
Muslims so then so like yeah so then
with the with the Bible yes you know you
have these men who inspired by God get
Revelation from God they're inspired to
write what they wrote not that they are
writing on their own unction um whatever
they want and then they're saying it's
from God now that these are claims
obviously but this is the the Christian
Paradigm yeah so what I'm saying is per
the verse in the Quran 279 yeah um it
wouldn't it to me it doesn't seem like
it's directly saying that the actual
Torah and the actual gospel have actual
have textual corruption rather that
there are people who have written fake
books and claimed it's from God so let
let me if let me let me ask you this uh
this this question so earlier we were
talking about the Sabbath yeah right and
the the commands are associated with it
that the Jews had a certain um commands
that they to do in connection to Sabbath
for a certain ideological reason yeah
okay and so the Quran um it goes against
that right the Quran doesn't affirm even
in the metaphorical sense that God did
any kind of resting but does it deny it
do do it deny that God arrested yeah in
any
sense that's how the Quran describes it
sorry that that there that God is is the
one let's let me talk about this verse
in order to really answer your question
in a thorough way all right so this
verse first of all it says God
is that God is the one who's is ever
living and he's a he's a self uh uh he
he is a self-standing or self-supporting
right that God doesn't need any outside
outside help to you know we can't feed
God we can't you know we don't we don't
give any sustenance to God right and
then it says that um that that he
neither he neither rests nor nor sleeps
right so what I'm what I'm trying to I'm
trying to answer your question if I
understood your question is that from
from an Islamic perspective this the
language that is used in the judeo
Christian tradition is is is uh not only
wrong now it might have had some
metaphorical understandings which again
I mean in the Bible it it has it in in
Genesis that God wrestled which has been
interpreted sometimes as angels as the
angel the angel excuse me that God
wrestles with Jacob and loses now this
is so what I'm trying to say here is
that in answer to your question does God
rest it all oh is that what you said
yeah I want to make sure I want to make
sure I'm not doing St maning you I want
make sure I understand exactly what
you're saying yeah so so um does the
Quran go against a correct sense in
which God rested right cuz I a guess a
correct sense yes in a correct sense cuz
we we obviously it's clear even in the
Bible that it even says in the Bible
that God doesn't sleep right so in this
way God doesn't get tired he doesn't
expire right and and so in that sense of
res that's what it seems like it's
talking about in the vers in the Quran
right he doesn't sleep or Slumber
meaning he doesn't fatigue and stuff
like that right versus the the type of
resting in the sense that he just simply
ceased this action so again from and
then this this issue actually extends to
many other issues within the
judeo-christian tradition in terms of
how Islam sees it so it's to what I'm
trying to say here is
that one things I'm trying to say is
most of all it's a matter of language
right okay and that the
comes for a global audience and so it
come it comes for a global for a global
audience and it comes to to give the
most clear uh answers to to you know
especially the issue of God concept okay
so that's what it that's what it comes
to do so can it can can God Rest in a
correct sense I mean for Muslims this is
not this is not even this is not even a
a statement to make yes but you but you
got to be able to cross that line right
you got to be able to to to think about
it and and really deal with it but but
but if you say that if you I mean if you
say I mean you know we take it many
steps further if you say that God if you
say that God rested okay or I'm
referenced earlier about about wrestling
got God wrestling Jacob and again which
has been interpreted at least by some of
the Jewish commentators as not really
God doing it wrestling but it was an
angel an angel that that wrestled Jacob
and lost and then he gets as a
consequence
the Jacob is given the name Israel okay
what I'm trying to say here
is answer and I should write it down
what you say correct correct resting
yeah resting in a correct sense yeah
yeah I want to make sure yeah in a
correct sense I want to make sure that I
represent you apprciate in a in you know
in the proper way now there again for
for Muslims there there this is this is
this is just it's it's from Muslim
perspective this is irrational
is it though it is I I'm trying to I'm
trying to explain to you again from from
a Muslim perspective I mean let's take
it steps further let's take it steps
further now we have new testament okay
New Testament and not just you have
Christian tradition which asserts that
that Jesus is God right isn't that which
would you believe you save it though
save that for the next one save that for
the next one okay okay okay I'll save
I'll save that
okay fine I'll say that for the next one
but let me let me just sort of make make
the point so the point I'm trying to
make in in and trying really I'm
honestly trying to address everything
that you're what you're asking I'm
really I really I'm trying I'm trying to
really without strawmanning you anything
I'm trying to address everything that
you're saying is that is that you know
when we say one thing like you know when
we when we put a weakness on God then it
snowballs into other areas it's only
it's only a weakness if you
misunderstand if you understand it
correctly it's not a weakness but but
what I said earlier is that okay still
you have to understand that not
everybody's going to be able to
understand everything that's true yeah
so so let me ask you this go ahead cuz
all right go ahead I'm listening I'm
list I'm listening all right so so the
Quran has descriptions of Allah
sometimes right um face hands stuff like
this now someone can you have this
mindset that these are weaknesses of
these are descriptions of mankind and
can let me ask you a question then oh no
no no finish your thought before I
interrupt you so so um if somebody can
if we if we're coming with this thought
that you know these are things that um
have room for misinterpretation and
misunderstanding does that mean that it
is absolutely incorrect in every way to
use that language yeah this is a good
question this is I think this is I'm be
fair to you I think this is a good
question and the answer to that I think
is very simple
is that you you look at let's use the
word hand M give me a hand please we
don't don't we don't we don't we
understand that mean automatically and
this happens in every language we don't
understand that as literally you know
you're giving me your hand giving your
assistance right so when you look at the
early Muslim tradition uh how these
things have been interpreted these
things have been interpreted in first of
all it's interpreted metaphorically but
second of all you have to interpret in
this case Quran it has to be interpreted
with other
verses that Quran or Quran Quran that
you have to explain or understand the
Quran in light of other quranic verses
right so if so so so the Quran says
wherever you it one of my favorite
verses actually and I thank you for for
referencing it you know it says to God
belongs the East and the west and
wherever you turn you find what his face
the the what
so this doesn't mean an actual physical
face with with a beard or something or
two eyes or two eyes or something like
that so these things have always been
interpreted in a metaphorical sense and
again you have to keep it in connection
to for example which I think you know
chapter 112 of the Quran that God does
God does not born he's not given birth
to God there's nothing in the creation
that's like him there's nothing like him
nothing exists like him yeah so can I
comment on that yeah please please that
that's the point that I'm making cuz you
you hit it up right on the nail that you
know you have there's a correct way to
interpret these things right so just
simply um because there is room there's
always room I think for anyone to
misinterpret stuff even you can be as
clear as you want there's some going to
be somebody who can possibly
misinterpret what's being said you know
but um simply because there is a room
for misinterpretation
doesn't mean it's absolutely wrong to
use this language as long as you're
using it correctly right and then and
just just final thought on this yeah
please um like as this as it's
interpreted correctly you in light with
the context it's surrounded and the and
the total totality of the scripture the
Quran or the Bible we can see what it
really means or have a correct a correct
understanding so from a so this goes
back to one of the theological uh
premises of Islam that because of of
misunderstandings and the potential for
misunderstandings this is again this is
one of the functions of the Quran itself
that it it comes to give very very clear
language now the issue of God's face and
and God's uh uh uh hands I mean I know
that these days there are people who I
saw on on YouTube a while back somebody
created this this kind of like weird
image of the Islamic God and they had
two right hands and it was looking like
really really really crazy like whoever
created that was smoking some serious
marijuana they were smoking some serious
marijuana when they when they created
that U you know as a way to to refute
Islam but you know rational people have
never looked at these expressions in you
know to create like again an image like
like that like a being with two hand two
right hands and and and all that so
these expressions like I said that's
actually a good example of somebody
taking that stuff and but again somebody
who I mean it's it's not our fault that
they smoke too much marijuana it's not
it's not it's not it's not our fault so
what so the thing again the thing let me
say this as well now the Quran it refers
to itself that it is it is a
text that it is a text for thinking
people for rational people okay and
rationally rationally people have have
Muslims traditionally have not
understood for example the um that you
know the face that there is there is
like U the verse we were talking about
in albak earlier that wherever you turn
you find the face of God no no one has
ever interpreted that as is as you know
actual face you know don't don't the
salafi Muslims kind of take more of a
literal view of these type of things so
what salais do yes and no okay so I'll
put I'll put it like that yes and no so
so yes in the sense that what they'll
say is that we affirm what the scripture
says MH but then what they deny that
what they say is is that to the the
modality of it know we don't know the
how exactly Kia CIA as they say in
Arabic that we don't know we don't
understand the how of it so so that is
and you know I respect that perspective
I do but this is not how it's been
traditionally understood so I'm trying
to explain this is not how been trly
understood because the Quran
says that is's nothing comparable to God
the Quran
says there's nothing like God right um
so you know we we have in other text as
well which is showing the the authority
and and the glory of God so the so the
authority and glory of God cannot be
should not be diminished by using
language that can can really just you
know take take someone you know take
someone really really out there now what
the Islamic claim is understand what the
Islamic claim is Islamic claim is is
that for certain reasons which I guess
we'll get into when get to the Jesus
topic for certain reasons that is what
happened is is is is and I'm going to
use this language now is that when for
example when Jesus Christ peace be upon
him when he was preaching or teaching in
his
environment when you know he uses
certain ways and and language again
which we'll probably get into shortly he
uses certain ways and and and and uh
language and speaking but then this
becomes misunderstood when it leaves
that environment okay and so I'm going
to give an American example which you're
going to laugh at I'm sure which I think
I think I think Sean here will laugh
about it and that is and and that is is
that is that at least in the 90s that
people would say what's up my dog right
you know this was this was this this was
a term of endearment but in most
cultures that's an insult you call
somebody some a dog and you know we go
outside and you have a little fight okay
you call somebody a dog so so imagine
someone who is unfamiliar with American
cultural context you know being called a
dog maybe understands English but
doesn't understand what the culture
means when you say that word dog yeah so
he means it as a nice term and but he
understands it as an insult what you
call me you know just you know let's go
fight about it so what I'm trying to say
here is that the the language itself has
to be really clear especially when it
comes to God concept and so again
reverting back or going back to the
Islamic claims the Islamic claim is this
is really the reason that the Quran
comes in the first place the main reason
or one of the main reasons at least is
to um to
remove the the the uh the confusion
about God concept and I know this is
going kind of going into the Jesus part
so I will stop and let you say your
thoughts so so U my thing is is this is
that um you know with all that
clarification okay the statements of the
Quran pertaining to the previous
scriptures okay versus what it says
pertaining to what the people of the
book say right how what they say they
misinterpret their own text that the
Quran uh accuses of them of this ACC
accuses the I'm sure I'm understanding
you the Quran you're saying that the
Quran accuses the the the Jews and
Christians of misinterpreting their own
text that's what you're saying okay
continue yeah so they distort the words
from the right places right try to hide
and conceal the truth and all this kind
of stuff right now not all of them but
there's a party of them that do there's
a lot of them right and so what we see
is is that there's a there's a
distinction when the Quran is talking
about the previous scriptures versus
when it's talking about the people of
the previous scriptures how their their
where they stand is in is an
incorrection and they need to be can can
you give me an example of the of the of
the of the uh distinction yeah so okay
so for
example um the Quran in CH 3: 78 it'll
say uh they distort the words um with
their tongues right okay and they say
that this is from God when really God
never said this okay right so that's the
people and then you have where the Quran
would say about the actual scriptures um
oh people of the scripture you have
nothing to stand on unless you stand on
the Torah and the gospel and what is
being revealed to you from your lord
right so stand on the scriptures not
what these people are saying and these
distortions and these misin
interpretations that's coming out stand
on the Scriptures it also tells them in
Chapter 2 I forget the verse so forgive
me but I think it's in the '90s but it
tells them to recite it in Truth right
to to recite their scriptures in truth
and that it's con that the Quran came
confirming what is with them what is in
in their possession right so let me ask
you a question here so um I want to make
sure that we're talking about the same
text okay so you you reference you said
the Quran says that the people of the I
think we're talking about the the
wording do you know where it is where it
says that uh uh um what did you just say
that that that they don't have nothing
to stand upon 568 568 okay I make sure I
I I heard you I I heard you uh I heard
you right sir 5
5688 so um I'm not plagiarizing I
actually I actually I actually wrote
this this is something I actually this
is something I actually I actually
actually kind of excited now yeah I
actually I actually wrote this paper and
uh I decided that rather than know
duplicating work that I would actually
bring it with me yeah that makes sense
I'm gonna let you I'm gonna let you keep
this after we're done I appreciate it
I'm let you I'm G let you keep this
after I'm gonna let you keep this after
we're done now now 556 he said 568 okay
now you know sorry 568 is what you
quoted yeah yeah all right so you know
look at context the context beginning at
uh at
566 and and then even you look at the
context before that is that you know the
fact of the matter is is that according
to the Quran that the people of
scripture actually did not in fact s uh
keep on to the uh Divine guidance but
with that said what does the Quran come
so as an act of God's mercy God
is is God is the most compassion Merc is
also the guide so as an act of Mercy
what he does in that environment is give
the Quran to Muhammad and that and that
this that the Quran is going to give
really that the that that uh that that
clarification or that or that guidance
and so meaning that the chance for
guidance the chance for for that for
that guidance that it emerges once again
if you understand what I'm saying so so
this is this is what I get from the
Quran right okay so the Quran is
supposed to be believed in and accepted
by the people of the pre of the
scriptures they have to and the reason
why they have to is because their
scriptures point to it it point to
Muhammad's coming it point to the
quran's coming and the Quran is in align
with what they have they have no excuse
right to reject the Quran and it and its
Revelation and its guidance okay and so
when we get to verse 68 this is where
he's telling them you have nothing to
stand on unless you stand on the Torah
and the gospel and what has been
revealed to you from your lord right
which would include the Quran they got
to believe in it all like right but do
you believe in it I no I don't there's a
reason though there's a reason okay so
there's a reason so the re the reason
why I don't is because of this issue
right I can see that the Quran is saying
this right I I can be honest this is
what the text says this is what the
Quran says okay okay the problem comes
when okay I go and I check the previous
scriptures and I put it side by side
with the Quran and the Quran as you was
pointing out with certain issues it
contradicts what the previous scriptures
teach so then then again the issue comes
why is there a contradiction between the
Quran and in the in the judeo Christian
tradition why is there a contradiction
so there are again broadly speaking
there are two or three reasons okay now
the first reason and I think I mentioned
this earlier the first reason is that of
language you know meaning that that the
tradition the joch Christian tradition
uses certain terms and I think we're
going to get into make more examples you
know later on in the conversation that
that the that Judo Christian tradition
uses certain language
that the Quran does not use and and so
because that language ends up creating a
confusion especially outside of its own
native cultural context okay okay so the
so the Quran comes along and uses a
different language and so this is this
is this is one this is one part okay
other part is is is really from the
quranic perspective it is you know just
outright correction like that that's not
what happened this is what really
happened okay that that you know this be
very blunt yeah so for
example the the uh the Jews and
Christians believe that there was a
sacrifice of Abraham sacrificing his son
okay and the Bible Genesis says that
about sacrificing your only son okay now
who was the younger son between Isaac
and Jacob Isaac and ishma excuse me yeah
so Isaac was the younger one ishma was
the older one so at no time at no time
could Isaac have been considered the
only son now what's happened of course
there have been traditional uh
interpretive humanetics that have that
have developed to say well you know
basically that you know ishma wasn't the
real EST anyway he's a wild Dunkey of a
man you know so that that that's can I
give a comment on this please please
please please so so the the word I'm not
being aggressive with you oh no yeah
you're good the the word uh when used
for only son is to point to Isaac's
uniqueness not I mean this is this is an
example interpretive humanties yes yes
this this is the point I'm so what I'm
saying here you I'm trying I'm sorry to
interrupt you what I'm trying to say
here and answer to your question why are
there differences so the second reason
is from the quranic perspective like the
Quran is because we believe the Quran is
from God and God is saying look you
weren't there I know what happened go
saying I know what I know what's going
on I'm sorry to be preaching I know I
know I know what's going on here and and
so as a consequence we understand it
that the the son that was to be
sacrificed was Ishmael but even then
there is there is uh something really
deep involved in that I don't know it's
really relevant to this particular uh
conversation but I'm trying to again I'm
trying to answer your your question so
first is language second is correcting
correcting points you know and thirdly
is again there it has to be some areas
of of corruption or areas of of uh of
some kind of mistakes that have happened
you know in in in the compilation of the
judeo-christian tradition yeah so with
points two and and three because we we
dealt with one okay two and three right
that um that uh it's coming just to
correct straight out some stories that
didn't happen and then um and then also
just there being textual mistakes there
and that's why there'll be some differ
okay dealing with um dealing with number
two okay okay so if we're dealing with
number
two and uh like it's it's saying that
there's some stories in here that that
is get that just got wrong the Quran
came with the the true rendition of
these stories right so my problem with
this explanation is that you have
examples of um like for example uh
chapter 10: 94 where all speaking to
muhammmad tells him now if you're in
doubt about that which we have revealed
to you then go and ask those who have
been reading the scripture before you
right truly let me see what you're
talking about okay for sure go ahead
1094 I'm listening go ahead go ahead so
yeah so 1094 and and just to finish the
verse he says uh the truth has come to
you from your lord so be not of those
who doubt right um and so the context
he's talking about you know previous
stories of Israel and Moses uh Unice and
stuff like that yeah yeah so he tells
Muhammad if you're doub now this
hypothetical obviously I'm not saying
Muhammad did doubt just hypothetical he
gives him a a little LGE if you're
doubting then go ask the people who've
been reading the scripture before you so
that would lead him to get rid of the
doubts that he might be receiving might
have of the Quran you mind if I thought
about that yeah so the the issue yeah
we're not we can't say that Muhammad had
a doubt he didn't have he didn't have he
didn't have doubts he's a messenger and
prophet of God who was who was preaching
this this message so yeah it is in a
sense a hypothetical but Hy hypothetical
in expressing what is that Revelation
came in the first place you know that
what is really T it's not saying that oh
because I have a problem I have to go
ask uh my Christian neighbor or my or my
Jewish neighbor it's not talking in that
sense what is what is talking what it's
talking about is again the fact of
scripture of of coming down because
Muhammad s alhi wasallam he did not he
was not someone who expected scripture
should come to him I'm sure you're
familiar with the accounts given the
Islamic tradition about how he received
Revelation he wasn't expecting he wasn't
expecting any of any of that to happen
and similarly the the Arabian society at
that time I suppose could be called from
using the Christian language Gentiles
you know that they didn't have exposure
to scripture like that right so this
this this was a new phenomenon you know
that a prophet comes among a people who
hadn't received a before yeah this was a
new phenomenon this was a new phenomenon
for the for the Arabs so this is what is
talking about not oh I I need to know
what happened 5,000 years ago so let me
go ask John you know next door my
neighbor my Christian neighbor John or
or Steve or something you know it's not
talking in that in that way in that vein
in that sense okay you understand I
understand what you're saying this is I
so I I respectfully disagree okay that's
fine that's fine that's why I appreciate
you man but so the reason the reason why
I expected you to disagree with me okay
okay um so okay so it wouldn't make it
doesn't make sense to me if you know if
it's talking in the sense that oh you
know it's just saying that you know
Revelation came down before yeah um but
you don't need to to check that if
you're doubting what you're receiving
because that's literally what it's it
says it says if you're doubting if you
doubt that which we have revealed to you
meaning the Quran right and these
stories that that Allah's been telling
him this Revelation he's been giv him if
you're doubting what I'm saying then go
check the previous scriptures right go
ask those who've been reading the
scripture before you and basically doing
that in the case right it's
hypothetically in the case that he might
have had any doubts about what he's
receiving he can go check these doubts
with the people who have the scriptures
and they'll be able to confirm like
actually yeah this is what happened yep
what you're receiving is true yeah but I
I think what you're what you're kind of
the missing here is maybe we're talking
cross purposes but what I think what
what's really being missed here is again
what the over overarching points now all
the look how big this is okay this is
this is huge pretty big this is very big
you know even though your copy is
smaller but whatever whatever whatever
copies you you have 114 chapters over
6,000 verses as we were talking about
earlier 30 sections 30 yeah 30 section
right so this is quite a lot of materal
for one man to receive a and then for a
society to receive be you know meaning
the Arabian society who who is now being
exposed to all of this discourse okay so
what what I'm trying to convey to you is
that what it's talking about is the
phenomenon of Revelation I know you
disagree but I still have to emphasize
my point you know in that what it's
talking about is the phenomenon of
Revelation phenomenon of re of re of
Revelation that was not experienced by
Muhammad peace be upon him before you
know before his exposure to it or to the
Arabs that at that time so so I I hope
you understand what I I understand you
can you disagree I don't have a problem
with your disagreeing but but um you
know nonetheless I disagree with your
disagreement so so there's an example
that I there gives he quotes a Hadith
where um um U Muhammad goes to a Jew who
asks and ask him am I mentioned in your
in your scriptures and these say they
say yes and then they kind of you know
paraphrase Isaiah 42 okay right and so
he gives this this example this story in
line with the verse right okay showing
that and not that Muhammad doubted you
know just that because he also gives a
clarification that he didn't doubt
there's a narration that Muhammad
says yeah so he he gives I just want to
make sure I'm clear and fair with him he
does give a narration where Muhammad
said say I'm not I'm not in doubt I will
not ask right um so that I think that
that's separate from when he just out of
curiosity I think just ask them hey I'm
am I mentioned in your scriptures the
Jew says yes and he ask where and then
he he quotes it right and so um I I can
see from iir's understanding here that
not that Muhammad doubted at all but
that he is that it is that Allah is
saying that you can confirm yourself in
what I'm telling you if you check the
previous scriptures not simply that it's
just just Revelation that existed before
I get your point I get I get your point
so let me let me put it like this right
so there I I have the Bible here in
front of me and as you've seen I I've
done quite a bit of reading of this
particular this particular copy I
brought it because I have all the notes
okay so I've done my reading here and I
see content in it that that I see
beautiful content in it yes I do I do I
see beautiful content whether I think
the origins of it is is irrelevant but I
see I see beautiful uh content in it I
also see content in it that you know
makes me kind of you know blink a few
times I I know I I see I see both uh uh
uh both ends but you know in the content
that that you know for for example and I
think you've heard this before is that
Muslims believe that you alluded to it
Muslims believe that that that Muhammad
peace be upon him was predicted you know
that Jesus predicts his coming and that
Moses particularly predicts his coming
okay Muslims believe that and I've seen
things in this book in that book over
there that blue book over there the
Bible I've seen I've seen things in
there which confirms that that the
Islamic or that Muslim assertion I've
seen I've seen that with my with my own
eyes okay now what I'm trying to say
here is that now God has God is
omnipotent God is omnipresent God has
power over all things okay and and and
and you know when you look at the life
of Muhammad when you when you when you
look at
that really those those kind of
predictions like for example Deuteronomy
18 I'm sure you heard Muslim talk about
this Deuteronomy 18 or I'll stick to
Deuteronomy 18 okay and there's another
one but I don't remember exactly where
it is but there is a there is a
statement in the Bible and I don't
remember where it is right now where it
where it it talks about a prophet who
cannot read and it's almost the same
description that's given in the Islamic
tradition talking about Isaiah 29 yeah
like I'll take your word for it for now
because I I don't remember like I said I
don't I don't I try to avoid quoting
stuff I don't remember all good but
anyway my point my point here is that is
that even in the midst of confusion or
in the midst of corruption or whatever
word you want to use that you will you
still see gems you still see you still
see like like oh wait that that that
applies would you consider those
Revelations from Allah that were intact
yes so then that would lead us to the
conclusion that that we do have the
Torah and the gospel that the quran's
talking about but we don't even even if
even if we were to go down that road you
know which I'm not necessarily saying it
that in that sense but even if we were
to go down that road again there are two
other aspects you know Muslims believe
and this is actually you know I would
say this is there's historical
confirmation for this is that these
these texts have suffered alterations A
and B is that in terms of especially in
terms of certain laws and certain ideas
yeah that that the quran's the quranic
uh uh um uh solution or rule is is
fundamentally different from the from
the previous one for certain reasons
okay and so we had this conversation
earlier about the about the Sabbath as
example okay and I think if we get more
into the Jesus part it'll be you know
more more good examples to uh to explain
what I'm saying here so go ahead yeah
yeah so I think this is a good place to
to wrap this this one up um if if we
want I can give like a little one minute
summary of my thoughts and then you get
the last word on that okay okay perfect
so um guys awesome conversation about uh
the authoritative scriptures um with
Imam wahed here man grateful for the
dialogue here man honestly this is
different than what I'm used to but it's
what I I prefer I prefer this especially
the conversation I had with uh Christian
the other day so um guys just
summarizing really quick um you know our
position as you know just from the
Christian standpoint we see that the
Quran has these verses where confirms it
says that it confirms the Bible or the
Torah and the gospel specifically there
aore the Psalms um um it says that we
have nothing to stand on and we have to
you know we have to judge by them recite
them correctly and to not distort them
stop hiding from him it also says we got
to believe in the Quran as well altoe
the problem that I have is is that when
I do that and I and I stand on the Torah
and the gospel um I see that it goes
against what the Quran teaches so if I'm
going to judge by the scriptures I have
I have to judge that the Quran is
actually not true and that's that's just
my that's my position here well okay so
my position is obviously the opposite
yes okay my my position is that we have
we can't allow Prejudice to get in in
the way okay so God first of all God
sends a revelation he sends guidance
through a prophet who we believe is a
global Prophet he's for Global
consumption and what if he the issue is
instead of nitpicking on you know these
uh this handful of verses that are
having
seemingly some connection to je
Christian tradition instead of
nitpicking on that let's look at the
overarching message of the Quran itself
rather than nitpicking on this thing and
that thing and we look at the
overarching message of the Quran itself
it is a it is it is a guidance it is a a
light for all Humanity to resolve all
the Humanity's problems and is it is
frankly in line with what Jesus came
with and in line with what Moses came
with in line with Abraham came with all
right right all right guys we'll getat
you on the next one we're going to go
into part two on the person of Jesus so
we'll catch you guys stay tuned for the
next video all right peace